bom ensinar não precisa ser chata
quem de vocês durante a sua vida como
estudante teve muito mais aulas chatas
tediosas do que aulas legais e
proveitosas
pois é eu também
durante a minha vida como estudante a
maior parte das minhas aulas eram
perigosas
essas aulas eram do tipo fazer cópias
intermináveis decorar para fazer
responder uma prova o professor falava
estuda pois isso vai cair na prova
com isso não me despertava o interesse
obviamente mas professor ele aprendeu
uma frase bem interessante que era
preciso ter uma conversinha com a sua
mãe
aí obviamente eu começava a estudar e
estudava com medo da minha mãe minha mãe
realmente é o chamo ela de pedagoga da
vida pois ela me ensinou muitas coisas
como valores o olhar né a questão da
palavra e ela me ensinou acreditar nos
meus sonhos é o que a escola tem feito
hoje é acabar com nossos sonhos porque
ela quer que a gente subir apenas para a
prova que a gente usa apenas para o
vestibular e os professores vão
replicando esse modelo de estuda porque
na prova e estuda porque caem no
vestibular e uma das coisas que a minha
mãe me ensinou realmente também foi
acreditar e não desistir facilmente
obviamente eu né sempre quando eu vou
palestrar eu gosto fazer uma pergunta
por que eu fiquei é muito intrigante
intrigado com essa questão dos
professores
e aí eu comecei a fazer uma pesquisa com
professores para tentar entender este
modelo de educação que está acontecendo
no brasil ea primeira pergunta que eu
fiz os professores que eu faço a vocês
também é quem escolheu a sua profissão
quem escolheu a sua função social e
porque eu faço essa pergunta porque
quando eu fui conversar com os
professores
eles acabam externando a culpa eles
culpam o aluno porque eles falam eu fiz
meu papel e dando aula o aluno não quer
estudar e quando você pergunta para o
aluno o aluno fala a culpa é do
professor porque ele não sabe ensinar
então quem é o culpado o interessante
saber que cada um de nós escolheu a
nossa função social seja não está
satisfeito com nossa opção sua
a gente pode fazer uma outra escolha
mudar essa função social
obviamente eu decidir se professor muito
cedo eu escolhi a minha profissão sem
professor com 12 anos de idade sim 12
anos de idade eu escolhi ser professor
eu queria praticar caratê é e aí eu não
tinha dinheiro em família era pobre e eu
comecei a lavar caiu de cachorro dos
meus vizinhos para poder arrumar o
dinheiro para fazer o karatê
quando eu comecei a praticar karatê
decidir bom eu quero ser professor de
caratê e aí pra poder claro melhorado e
tem um pouquinho de melhor condições e
fazendo outras escolhas não é por ser o
futebol e vendedor garçom sem segurança
de bailão até me tornar professor e
virei professor
quatro anos após um 16 anos já estava
dando aula de karatê num projeto social
eu adoro fazer projeto social e comecei
a dar aula numa creche de karatê
ajudei muitas crianças muito jovens a
terem sonhos e assim é muito tornaram
atletas mas o objetivo sim era ser
professor da sala de aula e eu escolho
ser professor de geografia eu faço
vestibular para geografia isso nos anos
1980 92 mil estava na sala de aula na
segunda fase eu já estava na sala de
aula dando ao geografia com o professor
substituto marcelo como é que você
começou a dar aula e replicá vá como eu
tinha aprendido fazendo cópia fazendo
decorar e falando vai cair na prova e os
alunos estudavam como a tentavam colar e
assim e seguindo é a minha carreira com
um professor muito infeliz porque eu
tentava dar aula me esforçava usamos não
queriam aprender porque ele está focado
apenas na prova e obviamente eu pensei
em desistir não eu vou desistir da aula
como eu lembrei da minha mãe né insista
não desista eu fiquei até o final do ano
vou ficar até o fim do ano
depois eu penso que vou fazer na minha
vida e aí fiquei tentando só que antes
de existir
comecei a recordar alguns professores
que eu tive eu lembro desse meu grande
professor josé vanildo o professor que
eu tenho no meu coração porque foi o
primeiro professor como ensinou a gostar
de estudar
ele era professor de matemática e aí ele
começou realmente
a mostrar alguns segredos para mim o
primeiro sorri ele sempre entrava
sorrindo
a sala de aula ensinava aqui com alegria
e sempre explicando o porquê das coisas
que usa até hoje quando vou dar qualquer
ao espírito sempre o porquê daquilo
trazer o dia a dia do aluno
outro segredo que eu uso muito hoje é o
elogiar o poder de elogiar os
professores muitas vezes hoje quando um
erra eles brigam com o aluno mas eu
expliquei pra você e esse bonito ele me
ensinou que não ele falou que o erro faz
parte do processo de aprendizagem isso
mudou muito a minha vida e tanto que
hoje quando falo com meu aluno eu tento
ensinar para ele eu falo isso pra ele
que o erro faz parte do processo de
aprendizagem
quando você erra está mais próximo do
acerto e assim ele elogiava os alunos e
ea gente acreditando e claro que eu fui
evoluindo mas isso não foi suficiente
para transformar assim tão a minha vida
como professor e eu vou começar a entrar
numa crise que eu tinha já a favor de
passar de aula quase desistindo mas eu
ia permanecer até o final do ano e aí
comecei a pensar e comecei esse bom vou
fazer para tentar trazer o aluno porque
eu perguntava o aluno não respondia eu
dava aos 42 mil na minha aula eu
estudava muito muito a dar uma aula de
qualidade
assim bom eu vou começar a perguntar eo
mesmo vou responder ontem que vai
acontecer
eu sou hiperativo tá então comecei a
perguntar para os alunos e falava bom o
brasil banhado por um oceano que o
oceano é esse ninguém responde é muito
bem pelo oceano atlântico estavam aí
achava engraçado mas eu queria que eles
participassem então se vou usar uma
outra estratégia eu vou perguntar pra
eles e aí vou dar duas opções pelo menos
1 ele vai acertar
comecei a fazer não deu muito certo eles
erravam até uma opção muito fácil eu
digo então eu vou dar
eu vou dar a mesma opção então falava
bom no brasil têm terremotos fim o sim
aí ficavam sim eu digo muito bem sim
o brasil tem terremoto e explicavam
porque que tinha terremoto e até hoje eu
faço eles começaram a achar engraçado
aquilo e ela começou a criar um outro
ambiente começaram a vir pra minha aula
já uma certa vontade depois estudando
também eu aprendi
e não é que a gente aprende basicamente
duas forma através da repetição e
através da emoção então se pensa bem
você pode dar seu primeiro beijo na sua
namorada na sua esposa foi uma vez
aquilo mexeu tanto emoção você lembra
como foi esse primeiro beijo então um
professor tem que usar a emoção fazer o
aluno realmente sentir a emoção na sala
de aula pode ser um simples tom de voz
então eu gosto muito de falar alto fala
baixinho falando baixinho segurando para
mim e vou mexendo com eles e vou andando
pela sala que dá um trabalho ficar nesse
tapete aqui então vai andando vai para
um lado vai pro outro e vai mexendo com
emoção o detalhe que eu falo isso ensino
ele brilhou como é que é a aprendizagem
antes de passar o conteúdo e do mal
falando como é que funciona a
aprendizagem não falo isso pra ele eu
falo que a repetição quando a gente
repete várias vezes uma função a gente
ficando cada vez melhor
eu uso por exemplo no dia a dia o
videogame que ele adora o neymar jogando
ele ficando melhor
eu falo do beijo já falei do beijo 3.000
falo quando se beija cada vez ficando
com um beijo melhor trabalho com
adolescentes começam aí eles começam a
entender e aí sim começou a mudar um
pouco a minha história na sala de aula
onde estavam querendo já estudar um
pouquinho mais mas eu queria mais porque
eu queria realmente eu sou muito
apaixonado pela educação eu queria
transformar ali a realidade até que eu
decidi eu vi um vídeo na internet um
professor cantando uma música que ele
puxa que legal
digo vou utilizar a música na sala de
aula e aí
logo depois veio outro pensamento tá mas
eu não toca nenhum instrumento
minha voz é horrível
vocês verão e aí eu digo mais eu vou
pular e fiz uma uma paródia por lá
escrevi a paródia peguei fiquem
ensaiando peguei um instrumento né eu
gosto muito de samba então fiquei
treinando cavaquinho treinando
cavaquinho calejando o dedo digo agora
vou na sala já ou não o segurar mais um
pouquinho e preparei aula de aula
inteira os alunos dizem exercício
cheguei pra eles assim vamos ver como
fica isso cantando e aí eu fiz a minha
primeira paródia os alunos ea gente
começou a cantar e aí eu fiz assim é
hora de se localizar o brasil
eu vou ensinar é no ocidente é todo no
ocidente
viro como eu não toco nada e minha voz
desafinada mas nós vamos continuar
e aí aquilo mexeu demais com os alunos
eles cantaram e saíram cantando pelo
corredor e aquilo me deu realmente a
sensação inacreditável fica cada vez
mais apaixonado e vamos começar com o
seu poder que tem uma próxima aula
quando é que a próxima ao rio semana que
vem e os professores que fez com esses
alunos eu digo nada tudo ao normal e aí
obviamente eu continuei e continuei
estudando e fazendo projetos e nesse
projeto da música e eu comecei a fazer
um projeto nas escolas públicas nesse
momento eu trabalhava em escolas
privadas
eu comecei a fazer esse mesmo movimento
eu até hoje eu faço nas escolas públicas
aonde eu faço aulões para o enem
então numa escola pública oferecido pela
escola reúne os alunos ensino preço como
funcionou a aprendizagem começou a
organizar os estudos o que é o enem como
eles podem né fazer uma boa prova e aí
sim depois a cada conto explicado vem
uma música dessa então hoje eu procurei
realmente fazer o meu foco é usar
através da educação ajudar a transformar
vidas como educação me tirou a uma
comunidade bem pobre me colocou onde
estou hoje eu conheço muitos alunos
conseguiram mudar a subir através da
educação eu comecei a fazer alguns
projetos além desse projeto do enem
eu criei um canal no youtube chamado
geografia irada aonde muitos professores
né e muitos alunos
eles entram estudante não duvida comigo
pra poder ainda melhorar a qualidade dos
produtos alunos no material eu acredito
eu fui lá e fiz um site chamado
geografia da pontocom onde tenho aulas
gravadas em estúdio investir cumprir
câmera montei um estúdio né
fiz uma estrutura gravei as aulas gravei
as músicas editei apostila e qualquer
aluno brasil nós temos já cerca de 2.000
a entre alunos e professores que estudam
totalmente de graça eu fico muito feliz
quando recebo um depoimento de um aluno
falando que aprovou no vestibular ea
gratidão que eles têm
e aí continuando através desses vídeos e
isso eu recebi com
vitte realmente foi mágico foi esse ano
tinha viajado brasil inteiro dando esse
aulão do enem mas recebi um convite para
ir num país africano chamado guiné
bissau um país de colônia é portuguesa
um dos países mais pobres do mundo um
país né que ele passou por inúmeros
conflitos pra gente tem uma idéia
nunca um presidente de guiné-bissau
terminou o seu mandato e eu cheguei lá
em guiné-bissau aceitei o convite e me
organizei para ir à guiné bissau para
palestrar a professores e alunos
então essa é uma das palestras poderes
sobre a gestão da sala de aula que um
livro que escrevi e o que me surpreendeu
em guiné-bissau realmente foi a vontade
que eles têm de estudar a vontade que
eles têm de transformar as suas vidas
através da educação
logo após as palestras para os
professores e eu pedi para eles que eu
queria visitar as escolas
eu queria e nas escolas para poder falar
com os alunos explicar a minha forma de
ensinar
eu visitei várias escolas e claro que no
começo me assustei com a estrutura e aí
também comecei na mesma hora de começar
a pensar eu vi que muitos professores
acabavam reclamando as vezes que não
faziam algo diferente porque não tenha
tecnologia
quando eu fui nessa escola por exemplo é
é o professor tem um quadro pintado de
verde apareça de ver ele ganha uma pedra
dirige se para dar aula dele e ele tem
que dar a aula daquele jeito e eles se
esforçam se empenham e faz realmente uma
aula com qualidade
então não temos culpa se você tenha
tecnologia ou se você não tem a
tecnologia a gente pode sim transformar
muitas vidas
e quando eu dei essas aulas sobre
atualidades e usei a música fiz músicas
sobre a história da guiné bissau sobre a
geografia física de guiné bissau e eles
cantavam em participando e quando eu
acabei por exemplo decidiu a aula uma
menina veio pra mim falou o professor
nunca pensei que estudar poderia ser
divertido e aquilo mexeu é muito comigo
em poder realmente transformar vidas nem
viajando pelo interior do país ea gente
conseguiu ajudar a transformar realmente
dar a idéia de expor
para o amor e falar pra eles que através
da educação que a gente pode sim mudar a
nossa vida e mudar a vida de inúmeras
pessoas
o meu recado que eu tenho pra dar pra
vocês é isso gente deve acreditar no
poder da educação jamais deixar de
acreditar no poder da oração porque é
através da educação que a gente pode
realmente mudar a nossa história o da
história do nosso país
e aí eu preparei uma paródia pra gente
cantar eu cantar obviamente que a gente
entender a geografia entender no brasil
sim nós temos terremotos de falar tanta
coisa enquanto a terra estremece não
pára
jamais abrir as placas tectônicas se
movem energia liberam você pai sente
vamos empreender escreve são gerados
pelas falhas no organismo e nas áreas de
contato bom uma convergente subducção
londres unamis acontecem é normal quando
só que acontece é mala
agora vocês têm comigo mas quando as
placas máxima terremodo mais uma chance
mas quando as placas mas assim terremoto
bom esse é o recado vocês não estamos
bem coordenada plano a nossa real na
somália fez no coração
[Aplausos]
[Música]